die halbe schweiz letztes wochenende das
tanzbein geschwungen in 30 städten gab
es kampf anlässen boomt wir haben einen
anders in basel herausgeschickt wurde
etwas ganz neues ausprobiert kämpfen
quasi nach dem karaoke prinzip und los
geht's
[Musik]
samstagabend in der kaserne gab man
kann's nicht zu live oder dj musik
sondern zu einer leinwand copy and dance
nennt sich das und es soll helfen
etwaige hemmungen abzubauen
hansen im club will man immer irgendwie
für irgendwen schönen da sein und das
muss man an dem abend also der computer
ist eigentlich nicht natürlich macht man
dann so schöne bewegung nach oben schön
auszusehen weil das da oben auf der
leinwand auch jemand macht aber es wird
von niemandem so bewertet wie in so
einem club oder anderen situation und
handeln würde die beiden berlinerinnen
die natur und anna haben copy and dance
vor drei jahren ins leben gerufen
nach gastauftritten in kamerun und
frankreich sind sie nun auch in der
schweiz
das prinzip ist darin fall
gemeinsam mit dem google chrome tanten
die zu musik videos
diese netz zusammen suchen und dabei
geht es nicht nur um die populärsten
stücke
ich suche nach videos die irgendwie
nicht die nicht sicher sind also die
auch nicht die in sich irgendwas haben
was was wirklich spielerisch ist oder
doch irgendwas vielleicht nicht klappt
oder wo irgendwie ich konnte duell
vielleicht interessant sind oder einfach
bewegungen drin sind wo ich sage das
müssen die leute jetzt mal unbedingt
nachmachen leinwand kommt die bewegungs
vorlag und die masse
es scheint als hätten die menschen nur
darauf gewartet ihren körper fern
steuern zu lassen
ein video sieht man ja was verschiedene
sachen man seinem körper was man
aggressionen auswirken kann oder um die
freude wenn man bedenkt dass tanz auf
jeden fall das therapieren und
befreiendes und auf jeden fall auch was
einem selber an seine grenzen bringen
kann
[Musik]
kämpfen bis zur expertin
computeranimierte musikvideos helfen das
publikum in basel ist begeistert denn
lustig und dann glauben zum meet greet
verlagern
am schluss werden man kann loslassen
verantwortung abgeben und darf ruhig
auch mal schreit nach tanzen in der
gruppe scheint energien frei zu sehen
[Musik]
die freude daran mal nicht konnten nicht
die kontrolle wirklich zu haben über das
was du mit deinem körper tun und eben
ganz neue bewegung dadurch ausprobieren
zu können weil du nämlich nicht du
selber bist sondern du willst eingeladen
auch mal nicht mehr nachzudenken dann
ist bewusst ein bisschen zurückzustellen
die identität zurückzustellen und
dadurch sozusagen im ohr er ein anderes
körpergefühl zu bekommen
einen abend lang bio tee oder hat
ihrerseits auch dieses rollenspieler
möglich copy and day ganz ohne virtual
reality wurde aufwendige verkleidung
[Musik]
und so ganz clubs gewicht aber sie
denken dass das was hier gerade gemacht
hat das ist doch perfekt kopiert haben
und bei weitem nicht so aus aber es hat
ganz schön leute das gefühl haben können
das und scheitern dabei auch in kriegen
vielleicht auch mit aber fest auch nicht
mit war ein ganz erfolgreich im moment
weiß irgendwie funktioniert so gut
improvisation durch nachtanzen ganz
karaoke hatten der schweiz definitiv ein
google co
[Musik]